hello everybody i'm jesse waters along
with dana perino
katie pavlich greg gutfeld and donna
brazile
it's five o'clock in new york city and
this is the five
president biden meeting right now with
10 republican senators at the white
house
that group of gop lawmakers trying to
cut a deal on covet relief
after biden has repeatedly preached
unity
but the far left is demanding the
president ditch the bipartisanship
and rammed through his almost two
trillion dollar plan
without republicans bernie sanders is
leading the charge on that idea
the question is not bipartisanship the
question
is addressing the unprecedented crises
that we face right now if republicans
want to work with us
they have better ideas on how to address
those crises that's great
but to be honest with you i have not yet
heard that
now the question is what will president
biden actually do
the white house and the media are
pretending the president is bipartisan
biden
but he's done the complete opposite
instead what americans are getting his
job killing joe
remember the new president has signed a
record number of executive orders in his
first week
that the far left absolutely loves then
again it shouldn't come
to as a surprise to anybody since biden
did say this as a candidate
i have laid out the most detailed plans
on the economy and on
issues relating to health care and the
rest of any president of modern history
i mean it's awful detail if if i'm
electing this passes
i'm going to be good to go down as
almost progressive presidents in
american history
so dana perino i think the big question
in washington right now is
can joe build a coalition i don't think
he has the votes to nuke 2 trillion
through
so can he build that coalition that he
needs
well a couple of things if you think
back to 2009 and that big stimulus
bill jesse one thing that we learned is
that every single day
the clock is ticking and the window
starts to close on a bipartisan deal
this one is actually quite puzzling
i noticed a definite shift in media
coverage over the weekend about the
biden administration already
uh just start now starting their second
full week uh
in office and that was this notion that
wait you said unity
but yet you haven't reached out to
anybody i find it quite remarkable that
these ten republicans are willing to say
okay look we have an idea
you know do you want to hear from us
instead of vice president harris and
president biden
calling them to the white house so
they'll have this meeting i think it is
basically
just a patina i think that the democrats
they want to go big they want to go fast
they want to go liberal
and bernie sanders remember he played
this very smart
he got behind biden early on he's like
obviously i'm not going to win i'm going
to get behind biden and i'm going to be
able to push as much as possible
he's actually accomplished a lot here
the other thing i would say is that
the democrats aren't even able to
solidify their own side
um one person who is standing out as
possibly against the big deal
that biden wants to do is senator joe
manchin of west virginia
he's saying whoa hold on a second this
might be too much it might be too fast
and they sent vice president harris into
his state
to do media which doesn't help him
president trump
won west virginia by 40 points um
there's no it's it's fine to go in there
and try to help a
senator to try to get to a decision but
you have to have the right messenger i
don't think they did that there
i think the window is closing on a
bipartisan deal they got to figure out
something fast
yeah katie but manchin's the linchpin
and i don't think he's going to go for 2
trillion
after president biden just unveiled 2
trillion in green new deal spending
and after a couple trillion went out the
door last quarter
yeah that's the big question here i mean
you have republican senators saying look
it's not that we haven't pushed through
a bunch of relief we've spent trillions
and trillions of dollars last year
and now we want to push through another
two trillion dollars we have 27 trillion
dollars
in debt and we don't know yet if all the
money we've already been allocating
has been spent yet but this is what you
get when you lose
the senate and you have bernie sanders
in charge of the budget committee this
is
all his caucus pushing from the far left
to get joe biden to do this and so far
in his presidency he's perfectly willing
to sign whatever the left pushes onto
his desk
and i wouldn't be surprised if he wants
to push forward with this as well but
let's not forget that republicans also
offered almost 2 trillion dollars of
relief
in october and it was denied by nancy
pelosi because they wanted to use it as
leverage for the election
now democrats are going to use this and
say we have a crisis on our hands and
republicans don't care about people
and they don't want to help with relief
and therefore we're going to push
through
anyway and some republicans now who are
meeting with the president today are
saying look
if we can't get together on covet relief
the rest of the presidency is going to
be pretty rough when it comes to your
claims
of wanting to unify the country
donna do you think president biden's
been off to a rough start he had his
deportation freeze basically tossed by a
federal judge he's had the keystone
pipeline blow up in his face
as he laid off a bunch of workers and
now this coveted relief bill
starting to hit the skids how would you
assess his first two weeks
well first of all it hasn't been a full
two weeks but i look forward to the next
four years
for obvious reasons the vice the
president has said that the plan should
be
i know hey it's going to take a long
time but i'll get it right for the next
four years president joe biden said that
the plan has to be big enough and broad
enough
to take care of the the problems that we
face as a nation
uh i know katie mentioned october when
speaker pelosi and others performed a
new
bunch of ideas remember it was may 15th
that they passed the heroes act and it
took months before the republicans got
serious enough to even come to the table
i think the american people want a
rescue plan that will help them
we should not be going from cliff to
cliff waiting for the next
round of unemployment checks to be
stopped let's give the american people
the relief they need
targeted and make sure that we can get
the kind of broad support that i think
will help us through this crisis
greg gutfeld take it away well first of
all uh
the stimulus check i guess was supposed
to be two thousand dollars and now
biden is saying it's fourteen hundred
dollars or as the dems like to describe
it
mostly two thousand anyway uh
it's not just the two trillion dollars
that drives me crazy
it's what's in there it's like the dems
keep sneaking crap into these bills
because they know nobody reads them
i know i don't read them it's like 5 000
pages you don't read them and they know
them
here's an analogy one that involves a
digestive process once again
imagine a restaurant where the chef
loves to sneak ex-lax into the entrees
so you got to check each meal to make
sure it doesn't go out with ex-lax
that's what the dems do in governance
they keep
sneaking stuff in and we have to be the
responsible ones
and they don't they're just assuming
we're too lazy to read
uh i i and i'm with katie we can't
forget
that in the process of trying to win an
election the dems
lost their humanity they deliberately
delayed a relief package so trump would
lose and it was a strategy
that was highly immoral but it was
successful
it got it it caused suffering among
people
but they won the election and i think we
need to have history
get this right that while trump was
cranking out these miraculous
vaccines the dems were shutting down aid
and they are miraculous i don't know if
you saw the new york times today but um
a new study found that the com that the
five vaccines
were with public results have eliminated
covid 19 deaths that is an amazing
sound bite right uh it almost
drastically reduced uh hospitalizations
but it was a
they looked at the data based on this
research trial
corona that would normally kill 150
americans out of 75
000 has reduced that number to zero
out of 75 000. that's a great parting
gift from trump to biden and also to the
country
that is pretty good and the audience can
look forward to more of
greg gutfeld's digestive analogies if
they stay tuned
coming up